hey guys we're back to new rockstars I'm
Sam basher your host for the day
whenever you watch this I'm here with
another one of my pet MCU rewatch
breakdowns and right now I'm about to
talk about the second installment in the
Avengers franchise Avengers age of
Ultron today I'm looking for Easter eggs
hidden references to other things in the
MCU and from Marvel comics or just
general pop-culture references so here's
your spoiler warning for the Avengers
franchise the comics and movies let's
kick it off with our main villain for
the film Ultron hooray played by James
Spader Ultron appeared in Marvel Comics
Avengers number 54 in July of 1968
originally he went by the Crimson cowl
we'd actually didn't know who was
underneath the red cowl which we
actually do see in this movie in this
scene right here he's talking to
Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch but
anyways Ultron has been one of the
Avengers main villains for decades now
he was originally created as an AI they
Hank Pym aka ant-man but in the MCU he
was created by Tony Stark and Bruce
Banner as for the title age of Ultron
there's actually a story from Marvel
Comics called age of Ultron which a
where ultron actually invades the
present from the future it's actually a
pretty fun story that involves Wolverine
and Sue Storm you know the Invisible
Woman as the main characters but that
story is way too convoluted and
complicated to do in an actual movie so
we got this but let's talk about our
other villains of the movie Quicksilver
and Scarlet Witch they first appeared in
x-men number four in March of 1964 now
in the comics their origin is a little
complicated originally they were mutants
they were the daughter and son of
Magneto and that kind of changed over
the years now they're just kind of
enhanced people in Marvel Comics that
look like they have mutant powers it's
complicated now let's talk about sokovia
now originally this country doesn't
exist in Marvel Comics it has now been
added to the comics after this movie but
it was an original creation for the film
I also want to point out that during
this big fight you hear Jarvis helping
out Iron Man in his headset also
coordinating the rest of the Avengers
Jarvis in the comics is normally a human
Butler not an AI which is you know it's
a cool you know use of the character in
the MCU but it is cool to see that
Jarvis is an integral part of the
Avengers team because he's very
important to any incarnation of the
Avengers in the comics also worth
bringing up the iron Legion that we see
in this film the century Iron Man suits
that go out to help the citizens of this
sokovia town they originally appeared in
Iron Man
300 and January 1994 and they were very
short-lived they were just a group of
other iron men and women's superheroes
and war machine led them for just like a
second but now they're just mainly
centuries now I wanted to point out that
Captain America's magnetic shield my
favorite version of the shield is in the
comics actually way back when in the
original Avengers comics that was
something that Iron Man made for him
which is pretty cool also when we see
Iron Man pick up Loki's scepter he has
that detachable Iron Man arm that we saw
in Iron Man 3 which was originally from
the mark 42 armor which was the star of
Iron Man 3 but now I'm guessing we're
working with the mark 43 armor but
moving forward we meet dr. Helen Cho who
was established in the MCU as Amadeus
Cho's mom now I don't know if she's a
mother yet in the timeline of the MCU
but Amadeus Cho is a very important
character to the Hulk storyline in the
comics they're moving forward to all of
the Avengers attempting to pick up
Thor's hammer now let's talk about who
can pick up the hammer in the comics
well kind of everybody because there was
this event called Secret Wars where
different versions of whole chrome
across the multiverse like the old like
an infinite multiverse all came together
all these different Thor's and created
with a Thor core and so we saw like
Gamora with a Thor hammer we saw a Groot
we saw a throg the Thor Frog super here
that I've talked about another Thor
videos which is pretty fun but in main
Marvel timeline we've only seen really
Captain America pick up the hammer and
actually use it and Black Widow in a
what-if storyline for the age of Ultron
story also moving forward we meet
another Wow a lot of villains in this
movie Ulysses Klaw now originally claw
first appeared in Fantastic Four number
53 in August of 1966 but in the comics
Klaw loses his arm after he kills two
chauka yes the king of Wakanda and then
T'Challa goes crazy he wants revenge and
he cuts off his arm and claw is able to
escape and then go get one of those
fancy sonic cannons but speaking of
Wakanda we finally get a name drop for
the country in this movie which is
awesome la cañada also worth pointing
out that Ultron is supposed to be made
of mainly vibranium in this movie but in
the comics he's made out of adamantium
yes the same metal that coats
Wolverine's skeleton but moving on we do
see some of the visions that the
Avengers are having some are references
to the future of the MCU but for Black
Widow we finally get to learn a little
bit about her origins and specifically
the red
now the Red Room is an organization that
brings in young girls to train them to
become assassins like the most
unstoppable assassins they're also in
the comics responsible for training and
brainwashing a Winter Soldier which is
pretty cool
but moving on we finally get to meet the
Hulkbuster he was teased in the trailers
and now we just see him in all of his
glory it was an awesome fight this is
actually one of my favorite parts of
this movie The Hulk Buster first
appeared in Iron Man number 304 and
actually in the comics fun fact Tony
Stark has different types of Buster's
for different Avengers like there's a
Thor Buster that has some magic imbued
into it that would be a really cool
armor to see in these movies but who
knows they're moving forward to the farm
sequence of this movie which I am NOT a
fan of but I didn't want to point out
that a lot of people were upset that
Hawkeye had a family in the movie but
this is actually true to the comics
specifically the Ultimate Comics also
during this scene this is a very fun to
Hawkeye's origins now originally in
Hawkeye comics we find out that he was
an Olympic athlete but he's only pick
Archer makes sense he's got perfect aim
and during this scene in the farm
between Ironman and Nick Fury you'll
notice there is an Olympic archery set
then moving forward we have Black Widow
and Ultron talking Ultron has captured
Black Widow and you hear him mention
invaders invaders brings Avengers
actually this feels like a fun nod to
invaders the very first team that Marvel
had which had consisted of cap Bucky
Human Torch the cybernetic one not the
you know Johnny Storm version of them
and named war but then back to our team
who just created vision visions origin
the comics are very convoluted in the MC
it's a little more concise he first
appeared though in Avengers number 57 in
October of 1968 originally he was
created by Ultron as his son to fight
the Avengers but as soon as he's born he
realizes that he is a good guy and he
decides to turn against Ultron and join
The Avengers hurrah we then get a shot
of vision saving Scarlet Witch after the
explosion of sokovia which is a hint to
their relationship in the comics they
end up getting married for a while which
is pretty weird since he's an Android
misson synthroid isn't enzo synthoids
they're moving forward to our Ultron vs.
vision scene at the very end of the
movie that you get the classic Ultron
look with this last century that we see
which is pretty cool also we get a very
fun not to the New Avengers which is an
actual team there are the Avengers and
there are the New Avengers with the New
Avengers facility in New York and also
with our post-credits scene there's only
one in this movie we the
thanos tease he'll do it himself just
like he did in the Infinity Gauntlet
storyline where he went and collected
all the stones himself which is pretty
cool also his helmet is closer to the
comic version of his helmet which I've
these big eyebrows not so much the
Lowell daggers we've seen the infinity
war trailer but still cool
that's enough comic book Easter eggs I
know there were all lot but let's talk
about some MCU Easter eggs real quick
like the Marvel 2.0 logo which is very
fun and also mirroring the first
Avengers film like that movie opening
with the tesseract one of the Infinity
stones this movie opens on Loki's
scepter which we find out is hiding one
of the Infinity stones that's
specifically the mind stone very cool
then moving forward we get to see the
New Avengers Tower with all the colors
and everything we did get a nod to it or
the blueprints to it in Winter Soldier
but now officially we get to see it it's
beautiful there moving forward to the
party we do get a nod to Bucky or at
least Falcon or the reason why he's not
in this movie is because he's working on
the missing persons case looking for
Bucky out there somewhere in the world
we ever get a nod to Ultron's main plans
in this movie early on in the film when
they talk about the Avengers extinction
extinction meteor meteor killed the
dinosaurs or made them extinct get it
there moving forward to our visions that
our heroes have what's Thor's vision oh
well it's just a nod to Ragnarok
Heimdall and the rest of the Asgardians
are saying that he's not going to save
them he's gonna leave them to hell hgl
which is a fun not to hello they're
moving forward to a Hulk and Hulkbuster
fight you see Hulk spit out a tooth
which is actually a fun nod to the
Incredible Hulk movie where a token
abomination or fighting an abomination
ends up spitting out one of his own
teeth also Hulk getting punched out
which is a callback to hole punching out
Thor at the end of Avengers 1 but then
back to Thor's vision we see the four
Infinity stones in a nebula which is
gold which looks a lot like the Infinity
Gauntlet also moving forward we get
Quicksilver mentioning that that Scarlet
Witch is twelve minutes older and ever
lets them live it down this also feels
like this is the number 12 is important
to the MCU
because we get a 12% joke in guardians
of the galaxy when they're talking about
the plan and also there's a 12 percent
joke in Avengers which is pretty fun
then moving forward we see a whole thing
sent off in a plane or a ship which is a
nod to the Planet Hulk storyline from
the comics recent off into space and
ends up crash landing on SAC are
spoilers though for Thor Ragnarok check
out our breakdown for that but now we're
at the end of the movie with the New
Avengers which consists of war machine
vision falcon Scarlet Witch
without Captain America very cool but
there was a version of this movie that
teased the inclusion of Captain Marvel
Quicksilver yes he was supposed to
survive also though spider-man that's it
for MCU Easter eggs let's talk about
some pop culture Easter eggs before I
leave you like the name Veronica which
is the code name for the Hulkbuster
which is actually a fun nod to Archie
comics Betty and Veronica
Betty of course is Bruce banners main
love interest in the comics but she
hasn't appeared since the Incredible
Hulk movie which is a bit of a bummer
Ironman mentions prima nocta which if
you're fans of The Office you know what
this is but the real definition for this
is a nobleman having the right to take
the virginity of a peasant woman on her
wedding night
in place of her husband so weird thing
to say also get some nuts to Pinocchio
but that's a theme throughout the entire
movie about having no strings on me you
even hear some music from Pinocchio also
since they're owned by Disney now
marbles on by Disney now make sense
there's also a few nods to Man of Steel
in this movie I'll get to the main one
later but you hear the phrase make the
world smaller which is something that ma
Kant says to young Clark Kent about
trying to control his abilities
also during caps vision is very
depressing vision we're get to see Peggy
Carter you notice the band actually has
the name Roy Thomas players which is a
nod to the creator of Ultron envisioned
in the comics Roy Thomas huh also
there's a lot of product placement in
this movie but my favorite is the
Gillette sponsor during this very
intimate scene between Widow and Hulk
you'll to see this Gillette can sitting
right there our other Man of Steel
reference is the priority of saving
everyone like the crazy priority of
saving everyone like the heroes main
goal should be to save everybody right
but they really hammer at home after man
is still kind of obliterated like just
mulched a whole city I do want to bring
up that this movie does have a lot of
kind of questionable jokes but my
favorite joke actually comes from vision
I was born yesterday it's pretty great
but moving forward we also hear a
reference to the 27 Yankees which is
considered one of the best baseball
teams of all time also you get a marble
statue of all the Marvel heroes fighting
Ultron and the during the end credits of
this movie and finally we get our Stan
Lee cameo he's a World War two vet in
this movie and in real life and we get
to hear his catchphrase excelsior fans
everywhere loved it one gripe with the
movie that I wanted to bring up before
the end how in the world with these
robots supposed to survive eight in
Apocalypse basically if an arrow can
take them out just a little flaw with
this movie but hey what
you guys think of all my Easter eggs and
hidden references did I miss some
probably let me know what they were in
the comments down below or let me know
which ones were your favorite I'm at
only stupid answers on Twitter yank out
the vowels from stupid make sure you
like this video share it with your
Marvel friends and subscribe check out
all of our other breakdowns are other
MCU breakdowns our Walking Dead
breakdown so there's a breakdown for
Deadpool probably on this channel go
check it out you'll enjoy I'm Sam basher
and I'll see it next